ya tenemos un montón de experiencia con
las series geométricas sabemos que la
serie geométrica infinita que es por
ejemplo la suma desde que n es igual a
un número por ejemplo K hasta infinito
de r elevado a la potencia N O sea esta
serie lo que hace es tomar el término r
a la k r a la k porque estamos empezando
desde k y sumarle r a la k + 1 má r a la
K + 2 más y seguimos así sumando un
montón de términos de hecho seguimos
sumando términos hasta llegar a infinito
Aunque nunca lleguemos a infinito y
Bueno hay unas cuantas cosas que ya
hemos analizado acerca de las series
geométricas como la proporción común
la
proporción
común
común que es la proporción que hay entre
dos términos consecutivos de esta
sucesión que cuando la sumamos nos da la
serie Okay la proporción común es tomar
uno de los términos r a la k Aunque
Bueno o sea no nos queremos quedar con
esta K más bien queremos aquí una n
Entonces vamos a poner aquí r a la n + 1
entre el término anterior
que es r a la n y cualquier cosa elevada
a la n - 1 entre esa cosa elevada a la n
por las leyes de los exponentes si
quieres decirlo formalmente esto es
igual a r y también lo podemos ver por
acá o sea Tenemos aquí Este término y
para llegar al siguiente término lo que
tenemos que hacer es multiplicar por r
entonces la proporción entre estos dos
términos es es r y lo mismo sucede por
acá tenemos que multiplicar por r y Para
pasar al siguiente término También
tenemos que multiplicar por r y bueno
todo esto de aquí es un repaso muy
superficial Realmente si no te parece
conocido deberías de ver los videos de
la serie geométrica ahora algo muy
interesante que probamos en esos videos
de la serie geométrica es que si el
valor absoluto de la proporción común es
estrictamente menor que uno
entonces
entonces la serie converge la
serie converge
con verge y también vimos que si el
valor absoluto de la proporción común la
proporción común es mayor o igual a un
entonces la serie diverge Así es que
algunas personas dirían que esto es un
sí solo sí Y esto tiene sentido O sea ya
lo probamos y por lo tanto ya es un
hecho pero sigue teniendo sentido si el
valor absoluto de la proporción es menor
que uno cada término es cada vez más
chico y no solo es cada vez más chico
sino que es más chico con la misma
proporción entonces cada que nos movemos
a la derecha como multiplicamos por r
vamos a obtener un término
suficientemente más chico Porque se
hacen más chicos con la misma proporción
entonces a la hora de sumar todos estos
términos va a llegar un punto a partir
del cual si sumamos el resto de los
términos esa suma va a ser tan chica
como nosotros la queramos Y entonces la
serie converge ahora esto es solo un
repaso muy superficial si no te acuerdas
de la prueba tal vez podrías volver a
ver esos videos de la serie geométrica
por otro
lado digamos que queremos saber si una
serie como la que voy a poner por aquí
converge Entonces tenemos la serie desde
que n es igual a digamos ahora que es
igual a 5 hasta infinito de n elevada a
la potencia 10 y Bueno Este es un
polinomio bastante grande verdad Y si n
aumenta muchísimo este polinomio va a
ser inmenso Así es que esta serie seguro
no converge pero voy a dividir n a la 10
entre n factorial y n factorial sabemos
que crece
rapidisimo Y seguramente crece mucho más
rápido que n a la 10 lo cual nos puede
hacer creer que tal vez esta serie Sí
converge a ver podríamos intentar usar
el criterio de la divergencia a ver si
nos dice directamente que esta serie
diverge pero no si calculas este límite
cuando n tiende a infinito vas a ver que
esto se va a cero Entonces el criterio
de la divergencia no nos dice nada
acerca de esta serie Así es que pues tal
vez converge O tal vez diverge pero cómo
probarías que sí converge pues tal vez
podríamos intentar usar un poco de la
intuición desarrollada en esos videos
acerca de la serie geométrica Así es que
vamos a ver qué pasa con la proporción
común entonces tomamos el término n + 1
que en este caso es n + 1 elevada a la
10 entre n +
1 factorial y luego tenemos que dividir
entre el término an n que en este caso
es n a la 10 entre n factorial Aunque
pues esto no está muy bonito vamos a
simplificarlo dividir entre un término
es como multiplicar por el recíproco O
sea que vamos a borrar esto y vamos a
multiplicar por el recíproco de este
término que es n factorial n factorial
entre n a la 10 n a la 10 y lo único que
estoy haciendo es tal cual lo que
hicimos por acá que es ver si tenemos
alguna proporción común y bueno si
hacemos unas cuantas cuentas aquí este n
+ 1 factorial lo podemos escribir como n
+ 1 por n factorial cierto donde aquí
este factorial se está aplicando
únicamente a esta n cierto y bueno eso
por qué es útil Pues porque así podemos
Cancelar Este término con este término y
lo que nos queda queda es n + 1 a la 10
n + 1 elevado a la 10 entre n + 1 n + 1
* n a la 10 * n a la 10 y puede ser que
ahorita tú estés pensando Hey Esta no es
una proporción común tenemos muchas nes
por aquí esta proporción depende de Cuál
es la n que estemos utilizando en este
momento Okay podríamos pensarlo como una
función de n la proporción de los
términos de esta sucesión no es una
proporción fija en común Entonces tal
vez no nos va a servir de nada pero
bueno en realidad lo único que nos dice
esto es que esta no es una serie
geométrica y estas proporciones aunque
no son una proporción fija en común sí
tienen bastante en común que la
proporción entre dos términos
consecutivos de esta serie la podemos
ver exactamente como esta función d n lo
cual nos dice un montón de información
acerca de esta serie no podemos utilizar
tal cual la prueba que vimos en los
videos de las series geométricas pero sí
podemos seguir la misma lógica porque lo
que realmente realmente nos importa es
el comportamiento de estos términos
cuando n es muy muy muy muy grande Okay
cuando n tiende a infinito y entonces
podemos fijarnos en esto en la función
de proporción Y en cuál es su
comportamiento cuando n tiende a
infinito si esto tiende a un número fijo
cuando n tiende a infinito tendría
muchísimo sentido pensar en ese número
fijo en ese límite como el límite de la
proporción común Así es que encontremos
el límite cuando en n tiende a infinito
de esta cosa de n + 1 elevada a la 10
entre n + 1 * n a la 10 y esto no es una
especie de Rito budu por ahí piensa en
lo que estamos haciendo O sea lo que
estamos haciendo conceptualmente es
buscando Cuál es la mejor aproximación a
la proporción común cuando la n es muy
muy muy grande
y vamos a ponerlo por acá porque ahí ya
no tenemos espacio pero a ver este
numerador es un polinomio de grado 10 su
término de mayor grado es n a la 10
después tiene 10 * n a la 9 y después un
montón de coeficientes con n a la 8 n a
la 7 y así todos esos términos pero su
término de mayor grado es n a la 10 y de
este lado en el denominador tenemos pues
lo podemos calcular directamente no esto
de aquí es directamente n a la 11 má n a
la 10 n a la 10 y entonces sacamos el
límite cuando n tiende a infinito de
esta cosa y esto es claramente igual a 0
o sea lo único que tenemos que hacer es
dividir numerador y denominador entre n
a la 11 y todos estos términos de aquí
que tienen un grado menor a 11 nos queda
1 / n y puros términos que tienen 1 ent
n a alguna potencia Entonces cuando n
tiende a infinito todos los términos del
numerador se van a cer0 mientras que en
el denominador nos queda n a la 11 / n a
la 11 que es un 1 así es que todo
esto es igual a 0 el límite de esta
porón entre términos consecutivos tiende
a cero conforme n tiende a infinito y
Entonces tal vez podemos usar los mismos
argumentos lógicos que con las series
geométricas aunque como ya vimos con
esto de las proporciones entre términos
consecutivos esta serie no es una serie
geométrica Pero tenemos una situación
similar o sea Entre más lejos nos
vayamos entre más grande tomemos esta n
la proporción entre dos términos
consecutivos se hace cada vez más chica
Entonces tal vez podríamos utilizar los
mismos argumentos lógicos que con las
series geométricas tal vez podemos
concluir a partir de este criterio que
si el límite de las proporciones entre
dos términos consecutivos es
suficientemente pequeño por ejemplo
igual a 0 Entonces tal vez podemos
concluir que la serie en entera desde
que n ig 5 hasta infinito de n a la 10
ent n factorial
converge
converge podemos decir que esto es
cierto tú qué dices y La respuesta es
que sí
podemos y lo que nos permite asegurarlo
es un criterio que no vamos a demostrar
pero que se llama el criterio
de la
proporción
proporción que también es conocido como
criterio de la
razón
criterio
de la
razón
razón también le llaman prueba del
cociente Y seguramente tiene otros
nombres por ahí y lo que nos dice el
criterio de de la razón o criterio de la
proporción o prueba del cociente es que
si tenemos una serie la suma desde que n
es igual a K hasta infinito de una
sucesión a n y tomamos el límite cuando
n tiende a infinito de la proporción de
dos términos consecutivos de esta
sucesión o sea de an + 1 ent an y
siempre recuerda que tienes que poner el
término n + 1 arriba si no todo está de
cabeza pero si tomamos el límite cuando
n tiene infinito de an + 1 entre an y
Bueno en realidad aquí tenemos que tomar
el valor absoluto de esta proporción
aquí no tomamos el valor absoluto pero
da lo mismo porque como son puros
términos positivos el valor absoluto de
esto es Exactamente igual a esto pero en
términos más generales sí tenemos que
tomar el valor absoluto de estas
proporciones el chiste es que si el
límite cuando n tiende a infinito del
valor absoluto de la proporción de dos
términos consecutivos es igual a algún
límite l entonces este límite l es la
mejor aproximación a una especie de
proporción común entre dos términos
consecutivos de esta sucesión
Y eso nos dice que las proporciones
entre términos consecutivos cuando la n
Es realmente muy grande se parecen
muchísimo son casi como una proporción
común y además son casi iguales a L buen
no lo que nos dice el criterio de la
razón es que si l este límite de aquí si
l es menor que 1 en entonces la serie
converge la serie
converge
converge por otro lado si l Es mayor que
uno entonces la serie
diverge
la serie
diverge y finalmente si l es = a 1 si
este límite es Exactamente igual a 1
entonces pues la verdad es que no
sabemos nada acerca de esta serie no
sabemos si converge o diverge y tenemos
que usar algún otro criterio alguna otra
prueba para determinar si converge o
diverge y bueno lo que hicimos en este
video fue nada más dar un poco de
intuición acerca del criterio de la
razón o criterio de la proporción que es
es un criterio muy útil Así es que
recuerda todo esto de aquí pero también
hay pruebas formales muy bonitas de Por
qué funciona este criterio y si las
buscas seguro te las encuentras por ahí
pero bueno esa es la esencia del
criterio de la razón toma el valor
absoluto de la proporción entre dos
términos consecutivos encuentra el
límite cuando n tiende a infinito y si
ese límite es estrictamente menor que
uno no entonces la serie converge y
bueno en el fondo este criterio de la
proporción o criterio de la razón
proviene de las mismas ideas con la
misma intuición que hay detrás de la
series
geométricas